support for big thing comes from
Microsoft delivering people ready
enterprise solutions designed to help
companies do more with less details at
microsoft com / people ready
thomas a stewart on the chief marketing
and knowledge officer of boozing company
approaches that companies need to take
to think about how to respond to the
fact that the US government and not just
the US government governments around the
world are gonna be taking a much more
proactive point of view about about
about carbon the first is to take a look
at stimulus packages I mean take a look
at what's the spending that is in the US
government stimulus package what's the
spending that's in the Chinese
spending that's in the stimulus packages
insofar as there are any in in the in
the European Union and sort of map that
out some of my colleagues have actually
done that with that with with clients in
the utilities industries and said look
here is the package here is where the
investment is here are the opportunities
for you to participate in this collect
some of this money and put it to good
use you know building you know better
power plants or thing or cleaning up
cleaning up your greenhouse gas
emissions and emissions in this order or
investing in in renewables so that's the
first thing is what's the map in the
stimulus opportunity the second thing I
think you need to do is to sort of thing
have a point of view of how carbon
constraints are going to be imposed
because they will be and they can be
imposed in any number of ways first of
all good simply be imposed by price you
know if oil goes back to 150 bucks a
barrel that's a carbon constraint so
that's one question it's a point of view
about energy prices and how energy
prices will change will they migrate
differently from one fuel to another the
second is will there be cap-and-trade
mechanisms and the third is will there
be carbon taxes and the fourth is will
there be other government things like
regulations I mean building standards
lead you know LEED standards for
buildings for example these are not this
wouldn't this simply says you're going
to have to meet this kind of a
regulatory standard in terms of
efficiency for your products or
efficiency for your buildings or
efficiency for for power plants or so on
and so forth so if you look at those
four things price regulation cap and
trade or taxation you've got to sort of
get a get a point of view and then I
think you simply have to be aware of
what's going on obviously there's a big
thing up a big international group under
the auspices of the
un climaxing in Copenhagen in November
which is looking at this you know what
will happen to the basically rewriting
the Kyoto Protocol the next that you
know the next treaty there so there will
be international stuff and there will be
national stuff and you basically have to
just sort of get people looking at that
systematically so that you have a point
of view you have the opportunity to know
what discussions are going on and can
start making the investments that you
need to make bearing in mind that a lot
of these are long-term investments you
can't just turn on a dime around the
building's you occupy you can't just
turn on a dime around some of the fuels
you use so you're going to have to start
making plans now because when the rules
come down you and they're going to come
down you're going to have advantage will
come to those people who were who were
ahead of the curve
no I do not believe I I do not believe
the garbage that says that we need to
pay outrageous salaries in order to
attract and retain right people Joe
Nocera wrote a very interesting piece in
the in the times in which he talked
about the sort of evolution of the Wall
Street pay package where you have a huge
you know bonus piled on top of a
relative sliver of salary it's sort of
you know your brand-new leopard-skin
pill-box hat it's like a mattress
balancing on a bottle of wine and and
how these came out of the partnership
structure of investment banks and they
were sort of an attempt to imitate
partner pay packages in in na in a
public corporation it does seem to me
that we've created a really sort of
weird incentive system I've been
thinking about this because because all
you know the line is we need to attract
and retain these people while I'm not
sure you actually want it to attract and
retain some of these people given the
consequences of what they did but it
does seem to me that we've created a
situation where in Wall Street in
particular the the financial rewards are
so huge that it has attracted people who
are disproportionately motivated by
financial rewards if you and think about
the comparison to Hollywood you know
there are people who are attracted by
Fame and are there are you know who are
deeply powerfully narcissistic and
Hollywood has created the opportunity
for people who need Fame to get really
really really famous and so it creates a
Hollywood culture designed to make it's
a narcissists paradise and we all can
laugh at it we all can talk about its
ridiculousness we can talk we know we
know the sociopath ologies that are
created with divas and so on and so
forth and Hollywood a similar sort of
thing it seems to me has happened in
Wall Street where you have created such
out of whack financial rewards that you
attract people who are attracted by
nothing other than financial reward
and and so we get even Goldman Sachs
says we're greedy but we're long-term
greedy you know at and that they try to
distinguish themselves from the rest of
Wall Street by saying we're just as
greedy as the rest if you're but were
greedy over the long term I actually
don't want people managing my money who
are greedy because they're going to be
greedy for themselves I want people
managing my money who are balanced and
who do want who have you know who want
and and so I actually think we'd end up
with a healthier Wall Street if if we
had salaries on Wall Street's that were
more like salaries and corporate
salaries and we would attract very
bright people they just wouldn't be only
money more oriented they'd be oriented
by money love narcissism by various
other things they'd be a more balanced
crowd and they probably do a better job
managing financial institutions support
for big thing comes from Microsoft
delivering people ready enterprise
solutions designed to help companies do
more with less details at microsoft.com
/ people ready